My God, we've had so many Disney prosecutions that Disney couldn't give them full numbers.
This is "Lion King 1½".
So how does that work?
This film is a prequel. Uh, sort of.
It focuses more on Timon and Pumbaa and where they came from,
and all the funny ways in which they were part of the original film, without us realizing it.
A nice concept, if you like Timon and Pumbaa, and I ...
... ehhh, I don't hate them, but I don't know if I want to watch a whole movie about them.
The story is, without surprise, as ordinary as it can be.
Timon is an outsider in his group and one day he gets the lead to make sure the hyenas don't attack.
Of course he is distracted, and the hyenas attack,
He feels terrible, and he has to find his own way.
He leaves and meets a companion on the way, named Pumbaa,
They form a bond, since they are both outsiders,
And yes, you see how Timon and Pumbaa join in random clips.
Sometimes it's funny, like when you can see how the "Can't Wait to be King" song actually ended.
But the majority is pretty useless,
You are pointing at the image and you say, "Hi hi, oh, so that's how it really went, ha-ha."
And for half the time there isn't even a real story attached to it.
When the story returns, it's ... okay.
I mean, there's a nice connection between Timon and his mother.
Occasionally you can sometimes smile.
But it's so strange to see such a good animation in something that is just a prequel for in between.
Like I said, they called it "1 ½".
Why does a movie called "1 ½" have such good animation?
The only reason I can think of is because it's Lion Kin guess, and that's one of their biggest properties.
It makes sense to give it such a nice animation,
especially since it must be connected to the original movie.
But, * sigh *, it's Timon and Pumbaa.
Why are such beautiful backgrounds used for Timon and Pumbaa?
And if there was a good story attached to it, a great story that would surprise you,
like Kung Fu Panda, or the Lego Film, something you wouldn't think would be great,
THEN I would understand.
But it is just Timon and Pumbaa that insert themselves into random parts, and it is not going well.
And I don't know, it's kind of a mess.
Not terrible, it still looks good.
The only thing I can really say about this is, if you like Timon and Pumbaa, you will like this too.
It is actually just the Timon and Pumbaa movie.
I don't hate Timon and Pumbaa, I just don't want to watch a whole movie about them.
But if you want to, maybe you think it's a great movie.
One or two of the songs are quite catchy, surprisingly enough.
That melody about digging always stays in my head.
And ... that's about it.
Like I said, I don't think it wanted to be more than it is,
I don't know if it was meant as a great movie or a great comedy,
It's just Timon and Pumbaa who are themselves.
If you like that, you like this too.
Myself? I think I like the cartoon series a bit more,
but if you are looking for better animation, then you should try this film.
Look at it, and maybe it's slimy, but still good.